bonjour à tous bon samedi on vient tout
juste d'apprendre que le couple dont on
a parlé dans les derniers jours au
couple de québécois qui se trouve en
bateau de croisière au japon a contracté
le canadien se coupent donc qui est
retenu au japon à bord du diamond
princesse a bel et bien l coronavirus
diane mais bernard meynard ce couple de
québécois en quarantaine à bord du
bateau au large donc du port de yokohama
font donc partie des 67 nouveaux cas qu
on a dénombré seulement aujourd'hui
total 285 passagers et membres
d'équipage donc de ce bateau sont
touchés par le virus on va tous deux
parlé avec la fille du couple chantal
ménard bonjour bon comment vous
réagissez à cette nouvelle madame ménard
cruellement
on avait des craintes depuis deux
semaines puis ça s'est confirmé ce matin
une vertu qui tombait et puis l'aitf
guardian de mes parents sont revenus
posthumes
donc ils ont contracté le virus on
savait qu'ils avaient des symptômes qui
pourraient qui pouvait s'apparenter au
camp à vireux sens dans les derniers
jours vos parents à ménard mais en fait
oui avait eu la fille c'est pour ça
qu'il va contacter le centre médical du
bateau avaient suivi les instructeurs
puis mais la fièvre monte et baisser des
fois il ya des journées on n'avait pas
du tout dans cette salade il y avait ma
mère un peu tout élève un rhume cacao
déparle pour le voyage donc le plus
grand symptômes c'était surtout la
faiblesse
les deux derniers jours il s'est juste
dormir des quatre derniers jours
seulement tu es presque pu mais ne l'ont
pas dit à ce moment là parce que je
crois qu'il voulait pas nous inquiéter
maintenant cette nuit à 2 heures et
demie à et un mât notre arène où ils ont
reçu les lettres sont venus gagner à la
peur de la cab et la cabine d'un médecin
qui aurait mis la liste comme quoi ils
testent poussif et qu'ils avaient
dominés se prépare un sac pour l'hôpital
dans la lettre se disaient qu'ils ne
pouvaient pas seul et que soient classés
dans le même hôpital
maintenant on essaie de faire des
démarches puis on a eu confirmation qui
serait probablement placé dans le même
tel n'est pas dans la même chambre basse
avait des chambres d'isolement mais il
serait au japan isme de terry as plutôt
ce sont vos parents qui vous ont appelé
qui vous ont appris la nouvelle
oui je dormais puis j'ai reçu l'appel
facetime en même temps que toute la
famille dans quel état ils sont on ne
refuse pas comme une bande va écouter
c'est déjà enregistrée en 15 ans sont à
l'autre bout de la planète pour malades
puis c'est l'inconnu pour russes et même
peau noire à part le japonais la botte
qu'est-ce que pas anglais donc ils vont
être séparés c'est la peur de l'inconnu
le ils savent pas combien de temps il va
être à l'hôpital non plus quand est ce
qu'ils vont pouvoir rentrer au canada
on sent que c'est un choc pour vous
depuis deux semaines de rapatrier mais
par un de leur faire faire leur
quarantaine ici au canada comme les
ressortissants chinois
j'ai eu aucune nouvelle du gouvernement
fédéral depuis deux semaines kilomètres
au plus trop tard mais les services
qu'on appréhendait est ce que vous savez
s'il ont été évacués du bateau de
croisière non je leur ai parlé à 5
minutes qui pas encore ça a été repris
parce qu'avec les nouveaux que poster ça
prend une ambulance par passager par
patient il voit la seule danblon donc ça
prend je crois que 177 aujourd'hui donc
ça prend soixante sept ambulances etc
c'est beaucoup d'organisation le je
crois qu'ils sont dépassés par les
événements sur le bateau font leurs gros
possible mais ce faut que ce soit
transporté 1
pour vous c'est l'impuissance là de
pouvoir essayer de faire quelque chose
juste de pouvoir communiquer avec eux
dans les prochaines minutes prochaines
heures ça va être complexe j'imagine que
tu es peuvent savent être possible m'ont
fait pas tellement à voir plus loin il
faille on quelqu'un nous aurait dit que
ray et pourrait leur fournir un titre
qui pour qu'ils puissent communiquer
entre eux et qu'ils auraient
possiblement faille à l'hôpital mais si
ils sont pas arrivés sur place dont on
sait pas encore on s'est posé quand la
prochaine fois qu'on va pouvoir leur
parler on appris dans les dernières
heures
madame ménard que les américains à bord
du bateau allait être rapatriés par les
états unis dont quelques centaines
d'entre eux qui vont être rapatriés dans
leur pays qu'ils vont subir leur
quarantaine de 14 jours donc aux états
unis mais vraiment rien du côté du
canada n'est ce pas rien j'ai eu aucune
nouvelle depuis deux semaines ainsi que
les australiens ou simon est rapatrié
demain les américains envoient intérieur
et ils vont poursuivre leurs 41 aux
etats unis dans leur pays
et c'est ce qu'on demande on avait lancé
plusieurs cris du coeur et c'est ce
qu'on demandait pour mes parents oui
maintenant qu'ils ont contracté le corno
virus
ça se corse on pourra trier ils
attendaient dès qu'ils ont le virus peut
compliquer mais pape est possible et
pourrait envoyer un avion quand même
pour ces gens là et les ramener safar
foigny si la demande est très bien dont
vous implorer les les autorités au moins
d'un retour d'appel j'imagine un suivi
de la situation madame ménard en
terminant oui c'est ce qu'on fait depuis
deux semaines mais puis silence radio
plus aucune nouvelle encore chantal
mineurs dont les parents diané et
bernard meynard ont appris en cours de
nuit donc qui sont qu'ils ont contracté
le virus à bord de ce bateau de
croisière le domaine à princess merci
beaucoup
nous avons je souhaitais le gouvernement
je suis pour les accents les québécois
et canadiens qui sont encore sur le
bateau pour qu'ils se défoulent même
fort que mes parents et sur le bateau le
plus vite possible
le message a été lancé on va faire un
suivi de votre corps et vos qualités et
nous aussi avec vous madame ménard
bonne continuation fillon fera de suivi
avec vous merci beaucoup merci